[Music]
um we didn't have any chairs
announcement
um coordinators approved the proposed
draft eisenda for 2021 September of this
year proposals for future meetings
coordinators agreed to close petition
number 482 of last year coordinators
lead to include petitions number 195 of
this year
1118 last year in the agenda of October
coordinators agreed to include petition
number 146 of this year in the agenda of
November coordinary coordinators agree
to interpretations number
1078 of last year
594 last year 353 this year in the
agenda of September coordinators agreed
to apply the urgency Pro Shader to
petition number
um
um wait a minute then I was here no yes
coordinators agreed to apply the ocean
Super Shadow to petition number 604 of
this year to include in the September
agenda coordinators decide to apply the
urgency pressure to petition number 574
of this year
um declared in October agenda
coordinators agreed to include petition
number 1015 laziness agenda coordinators
agreed to apply the urgency pressure to
petition number 628 in this year and to
include it in September agenda
coordinators did not agree to include
petition number 166 of this in the
agenda of the of September coordinators
decide not to deal with the request of
Matt Dancy to include petition number
480 of 2018 in the agenda of September
or October and decide to inform
non-attachment map of the following
options
um no attachment map can ask one of
ethical coordinators to take over their
requests for the coordinators agendas or
no attachment map can put forward their
requests for adding petitions to filter
agendas during the petty committee
meetings about the 0.5 coordinators
agreed to close petition number 814 of
last year 884 of last year related to
Pegasus on the basis of the
recommendations adopted by Parliament
coordinators decide to close open
petitions on juvenile from 2013 to 2022
on the basis of the petty report on the
factory visit to Germany under
functioning of the juvenile coordinators
agreed to close petitions number 1093 of
862 and 889 no no the these two the last
ones it was from 2018 and the last one
1800 800 sorry 889 of 2021.
okay
um coordinate in the 0.6 coordinators
endorse the draft program of the inter
parliamentary inter parliamentary
committee meeting which will take place
on 20 September of this year 0.7 Petty
coordinators agreed to reply to
employment letter along the following
lines Express Betis discontent for the
employment reply that does not address
Petty's concerns recalpatty's
involvement in disabilities issues and
the and in the United Nations framework
and the need to take due account of it
when dealing with questions related to
disabilities ask employee to clarify how
the disability rights coordinators would
be appointed and since that petty be
associated in employee implementation
and mainstreaming report about the 0.8
the coordinators agree to keep open
petition summer 98 2015
1134 2015 742
um 2018 and add them to one of the
forthcoming meetings coordinators took
note of the bi temperature 623 of 2018
from June agenda request to be kept open
for which the petitioner has two months
time to provide additional information
coordinators to aim 0.9 coordinators
took note of the new border decision
governing the participation of Interest
representatives in Evans Health on
European Union premises
um 0.10 coordinators took note of
registration of a new ECI entitled
taxing rate wealth to finance the
ecological and social transition
Point 11 coordinators took note of the
reply received and 0.12 no business no
other business so thank you thank you
very much nobody's saying anything so
means that
all these uh approval all these outcomes
are approved now we are going to the
public hearing
um first of all distinguish experts and
honorable colleagues members it is a
real pleasure to welcome you to this
public hearing on Schengen borders
issues raised by petitioners organized
by the committee on petitions in
association with the committee on
Liberty Justice and home Affairs so for
me you know it's a pleasure to join this
chair with
um Paolo rajel vice president of Bolivia
I would like to warmly welcome all the
participants and particularly our
experts Miss Corina Ulrich Mr Stefan
Salomon Miss Ellis Gil and Mr Fabian
gulzao and all the members the audience
and the staff present in the room as
well as remotely the committee and
petition has recently examined examinate
and discuss a number of petitions
complaining about internal borders
control among members say it's belonging
to the schenging area including
temporary borders between Denmark and
Sweden between Denmark and Germany
between Germany and Austria as well as
petitions on the extension of exchange
Schengen area debated petitions pointed
also to the cases of blocking borders
Crossing on the grounds of public health
concerns regarding covid-19 such as the
separation of exposes in Germany and
France as well as general general
movement limitations in Belgium
considering the number of petitions
received on this topic the committee on
the petitions decide to organize a
healing to give voice to Citizens
concerns over the reintroduction of
Border checks between some members of
stage those limiting the free movement
of persons within the European Union the
hearing will consist of two panels first
we're starting for the panel one
historical background and the second
panel is on internal border controls
controls in the context of the time
constraints of one of our speakers Miss
Gil um the first questions and answers
session will take place under panel two
immediately after her iteration covering
also the panel one in the framework of
panel two we will also listen to the
presentation of Miss silvigilion the
liberal reporter for the draft report on
the proposal for regulation of the
European Parliament and of the council
Amendment amending regulation
um
2016 390 399 on a union code and the
rules governing the movement of persons
across borders the concluding remarks
will be presented by Mr Paulo Rangel
chair of the Schengen scrutiny working
group in Libya so
um without further delay I would like to
give the floor to the experience in the
first panel to present the issue of
Schengen historical background please
let me remind you that you have 10
minutes for each of your contributions
and I'm very pleased to introduce Miss
Corina Ulrich head of unit of Schengen
and external borders in this immigration
and home Affairs director
bishengen borders and Visa the European
commission who will present
um this first part of the panel so thank
you welcome in 10 minutes
thank you very much chair uh honorable
memos
um thank you for the invitation to
today's panel and the possibility to
look back at Chang and look at uh the
today's situation in in Shanghai
today around 425 million people enjoy
the freedom the security and Justice
that shangan offers
Schengen is the largest area of free
movement without internal border
controls in the world
following the eighth enlargement with
the accession of Croatia on the 1st of
January 2023
the Schengen area comprises 27 European
countries that had formally abolished
the internal border controls
I recently attended a conference which
was organized here in Brussels and which
was called Chang kubadis
participants were mainly Academia and
retired EU officials who were actually
recalled how it all started so exactly
the subject that I'm dealing here with
today
and some of them refer to the Benelux
corporation which to a large extent is
reflected in the wording of the Schengen
convention because it already existed at
the time between the Benedict's
countries
others pointed at the French German
corporation launched and the
determination of some politicians and to
name just two uh Francois and Helmut
cool
to give a new Boost to the local
initiatives concerning the measures
applicable at the internal borders
I was actually last autumn in in
Schengen and there was a guided tour
actually guided also by a retired EU
official and he said in 1984
um Helmut Cole and Francois were
standing at the bridge that connects
Strasbourg and kill and they were
looking at these long queues of cars of
commuters that were standing there in
the traffic jam waiting to cross the
border and they said our economies
cannot afford this they are losing so
much money people are losing so much
time we should find a solution to this
so these are two of the parents but we
know that all success stories have many
parents
um and and the same is is the case for
for Schengen in
1985 only one year later on the 14th of
June five European countries met on the
princess Maria Astrid a boat that is
still there in the canal in Shanghai
and they agreed to readily abolish
checks at the borders between them and
this was when the Schengen area was born
since 2022 we have been producing a
yearly state of Schengen report in this
year's uh report which was adopted by
the commission on the 16th of May
we record some of the most emblematic
indicators proving the point how great
an achievement shangan is
in 2022 65 percent of world's tourists
who traveled internationally came to
Europe
making shangan the most attractive and
visited area in the world
Beyond facilitating travel within the
union Schengen is a key driver of
competitiveness for European businesses
shangan substantially contributes to the
well-functioning of the single Market
accounting for 23 million businesses and
15 percent of global GDP and this is
exactly what the founding fathers had in
mind when they thought our business will
benefit if they don't stand in the queue
this is a truly impressive result
however it took time and determination
to get there
Article 2 of the Schengen agreement was
still relatively modest it states with
regard to the movement of persons from
15 June 1985 the police and Customs
authorities shall as a general rule
carry out simple visual surveillance of
private Vehicles crossing the common
border at reduced Speed without
requiring such vehicles to stop
so it was basically kind of making the
controls lighter but not abolishing them
all together
only in the long term the founding
fathers of the Schengen area expected
the parties of the agreement to abolish
checks at common borders altogether
while transferring these checks to the
outside border of the EU by
strengthening these checks at the
external borders
furthermore
what we saw then was also a set of
measures to strengthen the Schengen area
within so measures that complement the
protection of the internal borders and
this is set out in article 17 of the
Schengen agreement
almost 40 years later we have
Generations who do not recall Europe
with internal border controls they have
been born when these internal controls
were long abolished and actually they
could not imagine I think to live in
Europe where you would need to show your
passport when you cross the internal
borders
tellingly the same article 17 of the
Schengen agreement that I mentioned
before pointed at the need to harmonize
in the first place the laws regulations
and administrative Provisions
concerning the prohibitions and
restrictions on which the checks are
based and to take complementary measures
to safeguard internal security and
prevent illegal immigration by Nationals
of states that are not members of the
European communities
harmonization of laws regulations is
therefore the very essence of Schengen
and Schengen is only possible thanks to
these complementary measures
historically the first breakthrough in
the process of Schengen emerging on maps
and political agendas came in 1990
with a convention implementing the
Schengen agreement which is at the
origin of many pieces of legislation to
which we are referring in our work on a
daily basis the Schengen borders code
the Visa code the return directive and
others so this all came from the
Schengen
implementing convention and then
developed into separate pieces of eulo
another breakthrough came with the
Treaty of Amsterdam and the
incorporation of Schengen into the law
of the European communities
and this created what we call today the
Schengen Aki
the need to respect the special position
of Denmark as well as Ireland and at the
time of course the United Kingdom led to
the so-called geometry where we have the
shanganaki that applies to different set
of countries then
um the actual EU law
the Treaty of Amsterdam then meant
replacing the intergovernmental methods
of cooperation by a more European one
where each of the provisions are
decisions which constitute the
shanganaki had to be linked with a legal
basis in the treaties
thanks to this process which was
continued in the Treaty of Lisbon we can
all contribute to preserving Schengen as
we are all playing a role in making sure
that the complementary measures are
functional
and keep up the pace with the changing
world
and we have to acknowledge that Franklin
is not only agreed achievement but it
can also not be taken for granted
maintaining Schengen as we know it is
hard work
and that needs to be done every day
the crisis of the last few years speed
in the area of migration be it kobit 19
as you already mentioned chair have
shown that that shangan is not something
that runs by itself but something that
we need to work continuously on that we
need to improve that we need to adapt
and in order to make sure that it
remains as um as as we know it
at the same time Schengen is not only
complex in legal terms but also
politically
it is very often linked with the
challenges related to assignment policy
even if years ago schength Asylum policy
have actually gone separate ways thanks
to the geometry variable
without denying the fact that both are
rooted in the convention we have to
respect this separation when we discuss
our secondary Law related to Schengen
this political complexity is also
visible in the context of the
enlargement process where a number of
issues influence the decisions of the
member states when discussing in the
council the decision on lifting controls
at internal borders
despite this complexity I'm confident
that changan will be even more
prosperous with the inclusion of
Bulgaria and Romania
the commission strongly commends the
efforts of these two member states that
have used many opportunities to
demonstrate their full commitment to the
Schengen project
we are closely working with the current
Spanish presidency in the council so
that a decision for the second accession
of Bulgaria and Romania can be taken
this year building on the important
political steps taken already last year
thank you very much
so first I'd like naturally to
welcome all of you and to say that is an
honor to be here as president of the
Schengen scrutiny group and on behalf of
our committee president Lopez Aguilar
and so I'd like to thank now mississ for
this historical insight about Schengen
that also shows how important it became
for all of us as European citizens and
especially the ones that are in
and also European cities that are not in
changing area but not really profit a
lot from it when they are in Schengen
territory now I would give the floor to
our second expert of the panel number
one Mr Stefan Solomon who will present
the topic assessment of the current
state play of the Schengen area
strengthens and weaknesses extension to
other countries including Romania and
Bulgaria the cost of non-changer so now
I would give the floor to Mr Solomon for
I'd say around 10 minutes
so
thank you so much
for giving me the flu so I've been as
you mentioned I've been basically asked
to address three points first the
current state of on the reintroduction
of border control so the current state
of Schengen second what are the economic
costs of maintaining these controls
third the full application of the
shangana key to Bulgaria under Romania
focusing again on internal border
controls I guess these three
fill an entire afternoon but I will try
to do this in the next 10 minutes and
just to be clear I will talk about these
points as a legal expert so from a legal
perspective as to the first point the
current state of Schengen
so the legal if we talk about changing
the legal and normative core of Schengen
is the very area without the internal
border controls and it is it is exactly
this school that has been undermined and
still is undermined since 2015 when the
first member states reintroduced
controls and that's still maintain
controls due to back then the terrorist
attacks in France and the increase of
Asylum seekers in a couple the number of
Asylum seekers in a couple of member
states
three points and let me illustrate this
um these undermining of the legal
normative coefficient with three points
first the number of controls Rose
considerably in 20 in the first 20 years
of Schengen from 1995 to 2014 member
states reintroduced controls a total of
90 times since 2015 this number Rose to
369 times this is an increase of more
than 600 percent
second the duration of these controls is
also longer before 2015 controls were
reintroduced for
a few hours to a maximum of four weeks
since 2015 most member states
reintroduced controls for six months at
a time and then continuously prolong
these controls
the third point that illustrates this
crisis of Schengen is that the nature of
the reasons that member states provide
for introducing controls changed
the Schengen borders code requires the
existence and the quote a genuine of a
genuine present and sufficiently serious
threat that affects one of the
fundamental interests of society end of
quote
prior to 2015 member states reintroduced
controls because of concrete threats
these threats included sport events
political Summits or the meeting of the
Icelandic chapter of the Hell's Angels
motorcycle club
in 20 years migration so from 1995 to
2014 migration was only used four times
as reason for reintroducing controls
terrorist threats were used only 10
times
this changed fundamentally since 2015.
a common feature of the controls or
rather of the notifications that member
states sent to the commission is that
they all emphasize risks that is
potential risks rather than concrete
threats
the upshot of this development since
2015 is that border controls are turned
from exceptional measures that are used
only on a temporary basis into
instruments of risk governance that are
employed on a quasi-permanent basis
in principle the court of justice put an
end to this practice in April of last
year the Court held in the in its
decision in London's police
that unless there is a new threat to
internal security that is different in
nature from the previous threat member
states are only permitted to
unilaterally reinstate controls for a
maximum of six months
although this judgment by the court is
binding on all member states they do not
implement it traditional checks in the
member state by member states courts are
also failing in France they can say that
held at the prolongation of controls by
the French government would be in
accordance with EU law they considered
da thereby adopted an interpretation
that is flatly contrary to the Judgment
of the court of justice
this brings me to my second point so
what if member states maintain these
controls since 2015 well it's five
member states which maintain this
control since 2015. what are the
economic costs of these prolonged
reintroductions well if we look at the
existing studies on economic status on
the costs of the of these controls there
are there are a couple of studies out
there so uh the scientific service of
Sherman bundesstock for instance
enumerates a loan for four studies that
exists in Germany there are two studies
that have been commissioned by the
European Parliament and at least one
study by a French government institution
front strategy
all of these studies differ both both in
breadth and in depth however what they
do have in common is that that they all
basically come to the conclusion the
controls at the internal borders result
in significant Direct and indirect costs
I'm pretty sure that many of you will be
familiar with at least some of these
studies so I don't want to rehearse all
of the findings in this studies but I
just want to highlight some or give you
some concrete examples of the indirect
costs on free movement of goods and
services
the to my knowledge most exhausted study
by the E4 instituted here at the
University of Munich
estimates that controls at the German
Austrian border alone
would result in a reduction of the
import of goods and services by 0.5
percentage points a year
in Germany that is equivalent to the a
sum of
6.3 billion euros a year
um to give you another example at the
Austrian border there are on a daily
basis more than 51 000 EU citizens who
commute from Hungary into Austria and
more than 14 300 EU citizens who commute
from Slovenia into Austria
those are the most recent data that I
found from statistics Austria based on
an estimated 10 minutes waiting time for
one Crossing at the border the indirect
costs for these Union citizens would
amount to more than 47 million euros a
year
I assume that similar studies exist for
commuters in Denmark and Sweden
let me come to the direct costs now of
Border controls in Austria direct costs
for Border controls amount to 88 million
euros in
2021 for and these are mostly costs that
are related to uh Personnel costs
one remarkable thing about the direct
costs is that to my knowledge in none of
the member states data on Direct costs
for the prolongation of these controls
are publicly available this of course
raises transparency issues
from a legal perspective the point about
these economic costs is that each time
member states reintroduce controls and
send notifications to the commission
these costs would need to be part of the
proportionality assessment
so as to measure or at least to weigh
the impacts and the effects of these
controls on the free movement rights of
citizens and companies in EU
really none of the notifications that
were sent to the commission since 2015.
basically included such costs
this brings me to my final point
the full application of the shangana key
to Romania and Bulgaria
Bulgaria and Romania are already fully
Bound by the shanghana key only parts of
the shanganaki do not yet fully apply to
Bulgarian Romania especially depart on
the evolution of internal border
controls
the full application of this
is basically a two-step procedure first
an evaluation must be carried out that
the necessary conditions for the
application of all parts of the
shanganakira Met second
a Anonymous decision but a council must
be adopted with the consultation of the
European Parliament
the Schengen evaluation report so that's
the first step stated already in 2011
that Romania and Bulgaria are
sufficiently prepared to fully apply the
rules of the shengana key the council
decision however was not adopted in 2020
in 2022 due to the veto of Austria and
the Netherlands and is it and it it is
interesting to look at the reasons that
the Dutch and the Austrian government
give so the Dutch government argues that
Bulgaria must and a quote Bulgaria must
Implement all the necessary measures
rule of law fighting corruption
independent Judiciary end of quote
in a simile win the Austrian Chancellor
cited the dysfunctionality of the
Schengen area as a reason for not
extending the shangana key
this basically from a legal perspective
perspect basically raises the question
so what are the legal criteria for full
application of the Schengen a key
to these countries are they fixed
criteria or are they rather adaptable as
the Austrian and Dutch government
suggest well a look at article two uh uh
sorry a look at Article 4 2 of the act
of accession basically indicates that
this our provision only refers to the
Schengen evaluation as the basis for the
verification by the council if the
conditions for a full application are
met
the specific criteria are then
determined by the Schengen evaluation
body
this variation and evaluation body
concluded already in 2011 the Bulgaria
and Romania made sufficient progress in
the fields of data protection police
Corporation Visa issues land C and A
borders and the Schengen implementing
system
so neither the accession ACT nor the
relevant secondary legislation on the
Schengen evaluation include any
additional criteria
which suggests that the legal criteria
for full application are fixed rather
than adaptable
the question then is what are the legal
implications that follow from that
does the council in particular have an
obligation to adopt a decision if the
criteria are met or is the decision of
the council a purely political one
for the sake of brevity I would say that
the criteria are that the criteria are
first legally blinding and that they're
also trusteeable by the court of justice
for a variety of reasons the wording of
Arctic Article 4 2 of the accession act
the structure of Rights and obligations
in the shanganaki and institutional
considerations among others
um I would gladly explain that if need
be further in the queue and a thank you
so much
thank you very much Mr Salomon then I
say that naturally now we could open a a
moment for Q and A but as our next
member of panel we'll have to leave uh
till 3 30. we will give her immediately
the floor
yes Mrs espel Guild jamone professor at
personam at Queen Mary University of
London and at the radbout university
the Netherlands she will present the
topic and then naturally we'll have q
and Day related to these three
interventions the topic is the appeal to
exceptional situations as means of
reintroducing Border controls within the
chicken area
the case of blocking border crossing on
the grounds of public health concerns
related to kavid 19 pandemics cases as
such as the separation of spouses in
Germany and France as well as general
movement limitations in Belgium so Mrs
Guild we I would give you the floor for
10 minutes and I would ask you to be
strict on this in order that we have 15
minutes of debate thank you very much
here and to be invited to present on
this particular issue particularly the
problem of the exceptional situations
and public health concerns and respect
of covid-19
I have very much appreciated the measal
Sun by my two preceding speakers who
have covered a lot of territory which
means I can focus very specifically on
the issue which is of particular
importance here
one of the things which neither of my
preceding speakers have commented on is
the write in article 21 of the treaty on
the functioning of the European Union of
free movement of persons for EU citizens
and of course their family members
now we have had a very good
um explanation of the reintroduction of
temporary Schengen border controls
within the Schengen States
uh over the last period and the
particular problems that we've had since
2015. I would add that in 2020 2021 we
had another set of problems in respect
of free movement which affected EU
citizens infinitely more profoundly than
a number of the other uh the
introduction introduction of exceptions
under the shanganeki in particular the
limitations to try and prevent the
spread of the pandemic and the eu's
response to that challenge to free
movement of EU citizens concerned not
only Schengen but also the fundamental
right the fundamental Freedom one of the
four pillars of the European Union
contained in article 21 of the treaty on
the functioning of the European Union in
when a number of member states and it
certainly wasn't all of them but some of
them introduced interesting intra-member
state border controls to prevent the
spread of the um Schengen virus a
measure which has had well was not it
was not shared by all EU governments
that this was going to be an effective
measure and it was not shared it was not
a position shared by all of the health
authorities but the first question was
the legality
an under free movement of persons under
the treaty on the functioning of the
European Union the only exceptions are
public policy public security and public
health but Public Health limited to
Public Health threats under an Annex to
the World Health Organization treaties
covid-19 was never added to that Annex
therefore did not constitute and has
never constituted a ground for
preventing free movement of persons
within the European Union
within the Schengen implementing
measures that we've heard about from our
previous speakers the limitations do not
include Public Health
so from the very first introduction of
intra member state border controls on
persons in respect of health issues we
have a problem of a lack of legality
under Schengen which the new packages
proposes to a change and a lack of
legality a
ugmenting measure directive 2003-38
this was commented upon by the EU Court
of Auditors in its 2022 report on
measures taken in respect of covid-19
where it noted that there were severe
problems in respect of the legality of
measures adopted to prevent movement of
persons and criticized the European
Commission in particular for its failure
in oversight
now every time we introduce intra member
state border controls
this doesn't necessarily affect everyone
similarly and I think that um Dr Solomon
has indicated this in particular it has
differential impacts in respect of which
parts of the population are considered
to be problematic in respect of Crossing
internal Schengen borders when there are
no controls on internal Schengen borders
everyone passes and the question of uh
their legality in
the minister of natural law when border
controls are reintroduced we see a
variable geometry in respect of who gets
controlled and under what circumstances
particularly in respect of the subject
that I am looking at that is the
separation of spouses
we can see that the reintroduction of
Border controls at inches again borders
which has has consequences for the free
movement of persons under the treaty on
the functioning of the European Union
has a negative effect or may have a
negative effect in respect of
particularly Third Country National
family members of EU citizens who are
exercising their treaty rights to move
and reside in another member state
has nothing to do with family
reunification it doesn't cover it it's
not relevant it's about abolishing
border controls
article 21
tfeu and directive
200438 provides an entitlement a right
of mobile EU citizens to move to join
and accompany by their third country
National family members anywhere within
the EU and indeed into the EU
the difficulties we've seen and we can
see this from the case law of the court
of justice from which member states do
we have problems in respect of Third
Country National family members seeking
to accompany or join their family
members we can see that the country's
suggested in this recommended in this
particular question Germany France
Belgium but in particular also the
Netherlands
are among the member states where a very
substantial amount of the casel in
respect of the entitlement of EU
citizens to move and reside with their
third country National family members
has come into existence the
reintroduction of temporary border
controls under the covet rules had a the
avoiding a new mechanism a
reintroduction of Border guards at
member state borders
which reintroduced and permitted the
questioning of Third Country National
family members of EU nationals moving
perfectly lawfully exercising their
rights under the treaty to move and
reside with their EU National principle
and under the guise of a dubious ground
of Public Health
increasing obstacles on the basis of the
street level bureaucrat application of
particular concerns in respect of Third
Country National family members became
an important obstacle for families to be
together and to reside together
this was not the intended consequence of
the reintroduction of border of
limitations on free movement on covid-19
grounds but it was an unexpected outcome
of that particular new power the
reintroduction of borderkin Border
guards at these borders and the uh
existing tendency in a number of member
states to view Third Country National
family members as necessarily requiring
extra consideration examination
interrogation and being blocked at
internal EU borders thank you very much
I think I filled my time
yes indeed thank you very much a very
interesting presentation then probably
if you allow me with open the floor
I would urge each member or uh that
wants to take the thought to to be very
strict only to put the question or
remark
as far as I see this is we have already
some some colleagues that are that asks
for the floor
uh and so I will give you I'd say one
minute and a half per person
so much as the plenary
to put your question in order that then
we can uh give to the three panelists
the opportunity to answer
so uh I would start with uh Emil Hadith
and then uh our colleague rappini
well so we'll have one per group now
okay
Emil please
thank you very much unfortunately
eight years down the line we continue to
go around in circles instead of thinking
long and hard about a solution or
thinking about how we can defend our
external borders better and
thank you it is good that we are
discussing the issue of Schengen borders
but now eight years after the last major
migrant wave we are still in this
Vicious Circle I'm a representative from
Bulgaria and I should like to stress his
these extremely important that Bulgarian
Romania should be
accepted in Schengen two countries have
historically always been the gateway to
Europe and for the last 12 years they
have certainly met all the requirements
for membership in the Schengen area
this is shown by a number of on the spot
checks various studies reports and it is
well known in Parliament it is something
that the European European Commissioners
something that the council knows
so
both countries should actually
be accepted and they should be able to
receive these deserved place in the
respect that their citizens deserve we
should not create
new factors that aimedly contribute to
anti-european sentiment
on behalf of SMD
is
thank you very much
I want to thank our free panelists and I
want to especially thank Mr Solomon
from a legal point of view he presented
very interesting things that we were
aware of but I think it was very
important for
someone like him a neutral person with
legal background to also highlight the
important points here I have a question
if time allows you mentioned cost direct
cost indirect costs you also mentioned
that
as we all know Romania and Bulgaria
fulfill the conditions starting from
2011 they fulfill the conditions
there is a commission
which checks if the technical conditions
are met
and discrimination
has given its positive opinion of this
but then the voting Council was negative
now my question is what is the purpose
of this evaluation if there is an
assessment and if all men Schengen
member states were admitting into the
Schengen space based on this technical
assessment then why do we now face a
double standard why are things different
now and what solution would you see to
this
now regarding the presentation from our
distinguished Professor Guild
we know that uh
movement was limited highly restricted
during the pandemic
on Shake Illegal Grounds
you can understand that the World Health
Organization
is working on a new
circulation certificate
in your opinion do you think that given
our experience with the pandemic we may
be able to prevent any such restrictive
measures be taken again to restrict
circulation to our
stefarto
from greens ah because you you haven't
asked for the floor did you
uh okay
yes no I apologize but here in my notes
I have I have no not your name so we'll
start with Mr giorgi and then we'll move
to our colleague from Prince please on
behalf of renew thank you thank you
Cheryl switch to Romania now so prepare
your headphones
um
remember
thank you we listened to the commission
representative telling us about the
history of the Shanghai space and how
this was established namely that the
citizens from Western Europe no longer
wanted to wait in line at the border
they found it pointless
the commission representative also said
that there was an assessment of the
financial impact
for the countries in Western Europe
this was happening 30 years ago before I
was born and as a result of this
assessment and based on the conclusions
they decided to no longer have border
controls nowadays Romania Bulgaria are
unfairly kept outside of this Schengen
area so now my question is if
citizens from Western Europe did not
enjoy waiting in line for border control
why are we supposed to do that
if
Austria
likes to keep citizens waiting in board
um in line at the border control why
don't they do that to their own citizens
and if
they want to control their own
borders so why are they acting on our
borders on Romanian borders
the right to veto was meant to cover
cases when a country's legal rights were
infringed upon so what is the link
between Romanian citizens Bulgarian
citizens and what happens
at other people's borders so if they
want to keep their borders closed they
can close the borders between them and
Germany or Italy or however they want
their friend Urban For example but they
can stop meddling in our business
you made a very good legal analysis
regarding the financial losses now can
you give us some details regarding
compensation for these losses because we
are heading that way thank you thank you
very much and now a colleague stefanoch
foreign
guests
you all three mentioned the same thing
namely that we're not talking about
legal criteria here we're talking about
politics namely that Romania Bulgaria
all kept outside of the Schengen area
based on political grounds and not
because they infringed any kind of law
on the country they fulfilled all the
criteria and they have fulfilled them
many years ago
and now you're telling us that we have a
problem in Romania now I believe that
you have a problem political problem
because members of the EU
do not comply with EU legislation how do
you think Romanian citizens will vote
next year in the elections how do you
think they will feel about the EU if it
cannot tell its own citizens that they
are
they do not respect the law
no we don't have a lot of activity
during election electoral times so how
are you going to act this year to change
people's opinion because I appreciated
that you mentioned you support Romania
Bulgaria joining this year so how are
you going to change people's minds how
are you going to change the mind of Mr
nah Hammer who keeps insisting that he
will keep us out of the Schengen area
please also go into more details
regarding this article name the article
4 paragraph two because it's very
important for Romanian people to know
more details about this and this has to
be done this year
and finally let me say that many couples
were kept apart
because of borders and This concerns
people in Western Europe as well not
just in Eastern Europe you just quoted
syncavichus who wrote volvadis
the novel
and he is an Eastern author who looked
towards the Western World how do we
defend all our rights
okay
now
um
for ECR
foreign
thank you so much I will go straight to
the point
one of the fundamental values of the
European Union is the so-called rule of
law
so every law has to be written on the
paper and published in an official
document and this is the protocol of
accession of Romania and Bulgaria to the
European Union
Article 4 paragraph two of this document
clearly states that when these two
countries are fulfilling their
obligations they have to be accepted
into Schengen now we have multiple
resolutions of the European Parliament
multiple Communications from the
European Commission and for official
positions of the consuls goal of them
clearly stating that both of these
countries not since yesterday but since
2011. fully
respected I would say all the conditions
to be part of Schengen so the first
question that I have to our guests here
Stefan Salman is can you consider that
the rule of law is respected in the
European Union if these two countries
despite the clear fact that they
respected the conditions to be part of
Schengen are still kept outside of
Schengen the second question we were
talking about compensations and a lot of
directors indirect costs
of the fact that these two countries are
outside of Schengen so the second
question is who should be liable
to these two countries and compensate
their losses for the fact that their
rights are not fully respected and
nevertheless the third question is what
exactly can be done immediately that
these two countries should be accepted
into Schengen immediately thank you
thank you very much now
um
ID
yes I know ID we don't have nobody they
left nobody I'm not an attachment
yes yes second problem
yes I'm here thank you yeah with full
support of Romania
problems
I want to touch another question which
which was raised it's reintroduction of
control on interior borders and ask to
Mr Stefan Salomon
uh he is estimation of what would be
happened if Shelgon border God would be
approved just as it was proposed by the
parliament at that time in Libya I was
called reporter on this question and the
opposition was just to give more powers
to commission not just allow member
states themselves unilaterally to
introduce his border control and the
file was frozen we had a big who are
always with the council which did not
want
such rights to to commission and we know
what has happened within kovid then we
had to step down and the Cancer's
position was finally approved to his
body code maybe Mr Solomon it would be
interesting to calculate also expenses
if
if our just European approach to this
reintroduction of border control would
win
thank you very much now I have three
maps in the second round but I have a
problem that uh Miss Gill expert she has
to leave so I'm going to give to her
um the floor to answer then I'm going to
give again to the three maps in the
second round and then to the SEC to the
salmon expert and the European
commission okay so now I'm giving the
flow to miss Guild
thank you very much and I'm terribly
sorry I I did let everybody know that I
I have an unmovable obligation that I'm
going to have to leave there's only one
question which has been addressed to me
directly which is the attempts by the
World Health Organization to resolve the
problem of circulation under covet under
under pandemic situations to have some
kind of uh worldwide mechanism and I
think it's an excellent idea absolutely
necessary but I think that we can go
further within the European Union we
know from the reports produced by the
commission that most of the restrictions
on movement within the European Union
and within member states were designed
specifically to save our health
experts and our hospitals from being
overwhelmed by too many cases all at
once and I think if we look at the
question of how we adjust our Public
Health Services to be able to respond to
pandemics rather than to locking
everybody down and putting huge costs on
the economy we might be in a better
position to enable continuing free
movement irrespective of a pandemic and
deal with health issues in accordance
with health law but I'm very much in
favor of the who
proposals thank you very much
and so
I'm saying sorry okay thank you very
much now um I have three more maps in
the second round
um Anna Miranda Green's group
one minute if it's possible because
the green group
European Alliance thank you all for the
presentation and as you know this
committee
receives hundreds of petitions many of
them
signed by a huge number of citizens
understand the situation but it's the
the they wonder why the council is
persisting in the uh on the that in the
fact about the senger key and about
complying with all the criteria and so
on isn't paying attention to counselors
and
so the Bulgarian Hungarian implementing
the key this has been confirmed by the
experts group and the conclusions of the
council in 2011. more recently the
fact-finding missions in October 2022
found that Bulgarian Romania had
continuously applied the a key since
2011. and the commission is
communication of November 2022 also call
on the council to make the nursery
changes
to this to end this discrimination which
as experts have said has personal
consequences environmental and
economical consequences in human and
it's borderline illegal illegal because
it doesn't have the legitimacy in terms
of connecting Europe Connecting People
connecting persons and avoiding
discrimination which is one of the
reasons that Europe exists
you have to finish I am finishing the
parliament adopted a resolution but the
question is for the experts mainly and
is do you see any possibility
of any measures that could be taken into
account to facilitate this right to free
movement for the citizens of Romania and
Bulgaria thank you
thank you now mrpesky
thank you madam chair I have a direct
question to our experts what is the
impact on the environment when hundreds
of thousands of trucks have to wait on
the borders
the borders between Bulgaria and other
countries how many tons of harmful
emissions for instance since you're
usually preoccupied about this
12 years have passed for these 12 years
we have covered all the criteria 12
years are a very long time and we have
heard many nice words for these 12 years
but we still haven't been admitted to
the Schengen area and the reasons for
this have mostly to do with the economy
with transport with Logistics the port
in Rotterdam is the largest port but
when Bulgaria and Romania are going to
join then we'll have constanza we'll
have other ports that will compete and
this is the reason why many do not want
Bulgarian Romania in the Schengen area
we have covered all the technical
specifications and yet
their various reasons that are quoted
why Bulgarian Romania should not be in
the Schengen area our truck drivers have
to wait on the borders
they have to live
without
their families because most of them live
abroad and they used and employed abroad
but not in their own country thank you
come in
see gracias president
thank you
I would like to speak Catalan but
yes
I have to call you to order sir
you know perfectly by what the official
languages are
foreign
not being available but this is about
the blocking of the borders between
Spain and France which borders Catalan
territory with the reestablishment of
controls during the covet period France
has been breaching the the Schengen
rules has been blocked a lot of borders
it's
and it justifies this with all sorts of
excuses terrorism and so on and one of
the it's causing grave
inconvenience in Catalonia for for drugs
and for thousands of families on both
sides of the mortars and France shows no
sign of changing tack even after the
court of justice having ruled that these
restrictions are contrary to the sang in
Coast because they exceed the time
limits allowed so we would like to call
the commission to act to have the
borders to Catalonia reopened and to
reform they saying in Border code it
should take the necessary measures to
ensure that one of the pillars of the
Union which is the free movement of
citizens is complied with by citizens
your time is up I'd like to finish in my
own language which should be an official
language
now let's move on to the experts
two minutes for the expert
foreign
let me start with the uh comment that
was given by the truck drivers when the
sabrikan agreement which was the
predecessor to the Schengen agreement
was concluded in
1985. it was actually the input is for
the conclusion of this agreement was
actually truck drivers German truck
drivers Austrian truck drivers and other
truck drivers in Italy which basically
blocked the roads and therefore demanded
political action to finally abolish the
Border controls which had been promised
in Prior uh EU documents
so I found this a very a very telling
anecdote and back then the political
leadership in Germany actually supported
in Bavaria actually supported the
political action of the truck drivers by
providing them with food and beer
what was otherwise an an illegal action
so let me answer the questions uh in the
order I basically sum them up a bit uh
so the first point was so the first
question basically concerns The veto of
uh Netherlands and Austria and what's
the purpose of this video well the
purpose of this video is that the
council verifies that the technical
standards which had been
adopted by the schengal evaluation body
are actually fulfilled so it's it's
really a verification mechanism so
um the council decision would then be
the legal basis for the full application
of the Schengen aqui
um what if um two or more member states
block it although the Schengen
evaluation had been uh fulfilled and
this is not and the Criterion Revelation
has been fulfilled and this is actually
not contested but other criteria are uh
cited well the solutions to this either
I could only the political Solutions I
don't know I could only point you to the
legal options and which kind of legal
options do exist so if the council does
not adopt this decision due to some
member states blocking the anonymous
concept decision there is always the
possibility for a member state or for
um another privileged applicants such as
the European Parliament or the
commission to bring an action for
failure to act in article 265 of the TFE
against the council
um the second Point basically concerns
the compensation for losses well uh I
guess we need to distinguish their
compensation for losses
um suffered by Romania Bulgaria and the
compensate and and losses suffered by
citizens speakers of um border controls
which are currently still in place by uh
and maintained by Austria Germany and
other states
um as to the second Point there's always
a possibility of State liability
um and you basically the conditions I
would see fulfilled so a citizen a new
citizen who has suffered a loss because
of our company which has suffered a loss
because of waiting time at the internal
border because of Border controls can
always go to National courts and claim
the compensation for the losses that
they suffered
I do not see this possibility in
Bulgaria and Romania currently and the
third question concerned the um
ep the European Parliament proposal
so the European Parliament proposal
Grosso model maintains a little
framework as it is in the sense that
border controls would still have this
exceptional nature the Council of the
commission proposal sees this a bit
differently and it would basically
envisage to reintroduce controls more as
longer term measures to counter longer
threats which would then shift border
controls for more exceptional measures
into longer term measures
um if the EP proposal is adopted
and the excuse me but you have to
conclude
yes I conclude by saying basically even
if the EP proposal is adopted the
commission what we still needed is
enforcement by the Commission in
addition to the enforcement actions that
are by EU citizens there is a concern by
citizens as this as the petitions
clearly show However the fact that EU
citizens do not take legal actions is
often the reason for this is often the
costs of the procedural costs that are
involved with this thank you
thank you very much now I'm giving the
flow to the commission
thank you very much very briefly
um on the internal border controls both
those that had as a reason kobit 19 and
and the current uh border controls that
are in place
um uh it is correct as Professor Guild
said that um we don't have a special
Public Health reason in the schengen's
Border code however we had the public
policy uh and we have the public policy
reason and um as as was also mentioned
in view of the danger that our health
systems were in at the time the
commission considered it legitimate to
put internal border control in place at
the very beginning of the pandemic
um further than we we coordinated a lot
of measures
um in order to get these con border
controls lifted quickly and we achieved
this um relatively fast
um however
um and this is also something that the
European Court of Auditors acknowledged
in its um in its audit the commission
didn't have the formal powers to do
anything this was all done on the basis
of
free floating coordination work and the
Goodwill of the member State and this is
why we proposed in December 2021 a
review of The schengen's Border code
which at the moment is being considered
in the deeper Committee in order to make
sure that in a future similar crisis we
will have the appropriate tools at hand
the same goes for the internal border
controls that are in place at the moment
for other reasons for a reason of
terrorist threat and for secondary
movements again the current proposal
aims to address
these shortcomings of the current
schengen's border code at the same time
as long as we don't have the revised
Chinese border code in place we um the
Schengen coordinator has made very
strong efforts in order to enter into a
dialogue with the the member states
concerned since October there are
regular meetings in order to find ways
to lift the internal border controls in
place and this has already been achieved
with view to the controls between the
Czech Republic and also on the one hand
and Slovakia and between Denmark and and
Sweden
on the accession Romania and Bulgaria Mr
Solomon has already said a lot now what
has the commission been doing the
commission
um has been since 2011
um continuously advocating for the
accession of Romania and Bulgaria we
organized last year and we thanked
Bulgaria and Romania for their
availability to do this
um uh voluntary evaluation Mission just
in order to confirm the results that we
had had in 2011 and as a result of that
the commission issued in November 2022
communication again emphasizing its
conviction that Romania and Bulgaria are
ready for the accession and asking the
council to proceed with this my
commissioner personally has been
involved during the entire mandate in
discussing with member states this she's
been very very active last year and she
continues to be active and as I said we
are now working very very actively with
with a Spanish presidency in order to
make sure that the decision can still be
taken this year thank you
thank you very much and now we move to
the second panel
foreign
he's going to make a presentation on his
vision of the appeal to exceptional
situation introducing borders controls
within the Schengen area the case of
Germany keeping controls with Austria
for years and the case of Denmark
introducing border checks with Germany
and with Sweden for migration regression
proposed so thank you very much and
welcome and you have the minutes
thank you I prepared a presentation
which I hope you can see or see and
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to address three important petitions
that concern the reintroduction of
temporary border controls between
Germany and Austria Denmark and Germany
and Denmark and Sweden which has been in
place for several years
based on my research I will address
first the use of temporary border
controls over time and then secondly I
will focus on the cases mentioned in the
petitions
but let me firstly go swiftly over my
introduction and I also need to note
that my view does not necessarily
reflect the position of my employer the
expert Council next slide please
[Music]
as we already heard from the previous
presenters the Shang area is a
Cornerstone of European integration with
considerable economic Mr Salomon
addressed this social and also symbolic
significance
so let me just say that
um I think it's quite understandable
that citizens and economic actors are
concerned when temporary border controls
are in place for an extended period of
time
next slide please
enables member states to reintroduce
temporary border controls in specific
cases which you can see on the slide
but I'm sure you are aware of
but only limited for a fixed period of
time and as a last resort measure I
think that's pretty important
in my view temporary border controls at
least one slide back sorry in my view
temporary border controls can be seen as
a pressure release valve that is
supposed to safeguard the scheng area in
specific circumstances
but how are temporary border controls
actually used next slide please
looking at the figures on the right
um You can see that you can see the
number and average length of temporary
border controls over time
on the top it's the number of borders
land borders affected and Below you see
the average number the length of the
temporary border controls
and it's apparent that for a long time
temporary border controls were used as a
flexible short-term solution to fairly
circumscribed issues like political
meetings or sport events for instance
clearly since 2015 something changed
temporary border controls are now used
much more often
and also for a longer period of time
there's really been a strong shift
we can also see that temporary border
controls are
most widespread at the beginning of
Crisis events and we've already heard
about the migration crisis of 2015 and
16 and the covet pandemic which was
addressed by Miss Guild next slide
please
let me now say a few words about the
reasons that member states give to
justify the reintroduction of temporary
border controls
the figure on the left shows the main
reason for the reintroduction of
temporary border controls over time
In Sum the reasons changed considerably
from the protection of circumstances
circumscribed events
such as sport events
to immigration control
the prevention of terrorism
and recently
mixed motives and overlapping motives
we can also see and learn from the
figure that there are several heavy
users of temporary border controls
these are member states in the north and
west and north and Western Europe
in particular Germany and Austria
Germany kept temporary border controls
since 2015 so nine years by now
Denmark and Germany since 2016 so eight
years
and Denmark and Sweden
since 2018 so for six years
and Scholars underline that the multiple
extensions which add up to several years
of temporary border controls means that
they have become quasi quasi-permanent
so they are not not a temporary measure
anymore but a permanent measure or one
could say The New Normal next slide
please
looking at the cases mentioned in the
politicians
we can see that since 2015 major events
are invoked to justify temporary border
controls
these are Refugee movement so-called
secondary movements in the case of
Germany and Austria
the pandemic of course also for
several years
and in the case of Denmark and Germany
it's a mixture of migration organized
crime and terrorism
and by now also other reasons for
instance the war between the invasion of
Ukraine by Russia
and between the Border Denmark Sweden
it's mainly organized crime and
terrorism
the mixture and overlapping reasons make
it really difficult to assess the
effectiveness and proportion
professionality of measures
it's also difficult to determine whether
temporary border controls are an
appropriate response to the to the
respective threats
because measurable objectives are rarely
established in the notifications
provided by the by the member states
at the same time we learned that
temporary border controls entail
measurable economic costs
and I would also like to add that they
also my term European European
integration but also European
identification
for people traveling across the borders
of the Shang area
next slide please
so I come to my conclusion
since 2015 temporary border controls at
infrastank Borders have been prolonged
for multiple times
and at the moment I think it's fair to
say that they lost their temporary
nature
and have become quasi-permanent
what's more the reasons are no longer
um specific events but instead mixed
motives and yeah major crisis but also
mixed and overlapped lapping reasons are
given by the member states
and the mixing of
um motives and reasons that are
mentioned make it really hard to assess
the property proper to National lead
proper additionality sorry and
effectiveness of the measures
I can't delve into detail here but let
me also mention that the resort to
Temporary border controls of course also
related to larger problems affecting the
whole Shang area for instance the first
country of Entry principle that
um that very currently see several
deviations which is enshrined as a
Dublin regulation
next slide please
you can see some of the literature I
used to in my presentation
and next slide please
let me thank you for your attention and
I'm looking forward to the Q a thank you
thank you very much now I'm giving the
floor to miss gigam that um she is
thank you very much Madam chair I'm a
member of both committees Petty and
liebe and I have to tell you that there
are two very different atmospheres for
each one especially when it comes to the
matter of Schengen
many of the things I wanted to say in my
direct introduction have already been
said but I just wanted to say that in
December 2021 the commission came
forward with its proposal for to modify
the Schengen code why was a reform
necessary this has already been
mentioned but Schengen has faced a
number of challenges in recent years
whereas it represents from my point of
view and I can imagine that this applies
to a large number of members of these
two committees as well that it's one of
the biggest achievements of the European
project a single space that allows
millions of passengers to travel freely
since 2015 as we've just been reminded
this freedom of movement has no longer
been assured between certain member
states some of them such as France
Germany Austria and Sweden have decided
to reintroduce checks at the border for
various reasons that we've heard about
terrorism being one
when it's functioning normally the
Schengen area might also reintroduce
internal checks for a maximum duration
of six months and I have to insist upon
that point we also had a reminder of
this in uh in 2022 by the court of
justice and yet a number of member
states still have checks in place for
years and that wasn't mentioned by the
last speaker but France as well has had
them in place for seven years in
domestic checks the commission could
have launched infringement proceedings
but it has not done so it's preferred
instead to adapt the rules of the code
and as we already just heard about
to it's tried to sort things out face to
face there are several elements that
have been proposed by the commission as
part of its revision process which have
seemed problematic firstly the
commission decided to introduce into the
text the definition of the
instrumentalization of migrants as a
reminder the commission has proposed a
specific regulation against
instrumentalization of migrants I
believe it's still under negotiation
with a view to responding to these situ
the situations as faced by Belarus in
so that this is not a then punishing
migrants that so that they're not
victims of this regime but on the other
hand there are problems with the
definition of asylum and migrate
migration and they have no place in a
text that deals with managing this
internal Zone another contentious point
is the article 23A which um it
introduces an uh a first proposal on
about member states it's it's not
relevant to add new procedures to
internal borders when we still have very
vague Contours it seems that the
commission has tried to resolve the
problems linked to migration which were
not regulated in the text on the subject
and Schengen is not there to make up for
shortcomings in other aspects of
European legislation in the revision of
the code the Commissioners also
proposing to revise the returns
directive as well which would allow
member states to assign new bilateral
agreements on the subject that goes that
runs counter to what the European Union
aims to do and as counter to the
principles of Schengen which as I've
said
requires there to be no checks
um carried out in addition to the ones
that I've just mentioned introduction of
this uh of my migrants as being a reason
for getting rid of internal checks is is
it does not hold up for example if there
are threats against domestic security
that would be a reason but in in reality
it's being used to cut counter migrants
moving and another reason for it
reintroducing good checks as well has
been uh has been happening without these
exceptional circumstances and the
commission has authorized that for two
years already as you can say I haven't
um really mentioned the commission I
haven't really bathed the commissioning
glory in this uh opinion but I believe
that Schengen is of such vital
importance to the European Union that I
had to present it in this way and that's
why in this draft report that I
submitted in November 2022 I really
wanted us to revisit the original Spirit
of a Schengen no controls I suggest that
reintroduction of these checks by member
states should be of Last Resort and for
a specific period of time and sometimes
I think that it we really need to have
say this again I've um got rid of
article 23A as well as the definition of
instrumentalization and also using
migration as the reason for introducing
checks again and also the recasting of
the returns directive I wanted to Grant
a greater space for the Parliament and
the commission to do what is necessary
which will allow to us to put an end to
these multitude of checks um that are
happening some of them have been placed
in uh in place for a number of years
and we've also drawn on the um 2022
court of justice ruling as well which
seems to be in keeping with this view to
end on it on a positive note I would
support the commission when it comes to
how the pandemic was mentioned and
that's all already been mentioned by a
previous speaker
in January of 2023 those checks were
still in place however and as you might
have seen they are rather complex during
these negotiations there are two
different visions of Schengen facing
each other part of the hemicycle
seems to be very focused on opposing
this report that I've proposed and this
has drawn out the negotiations for quite
a long time however there seems to be an
agreement on the vast part and the
majority of the text there are two
points that need to be sorted out
internal returns as part of article 23 a
and also returns as part of exceptional
circumstances including crises a number
of concessions have been made I admit
I've worked on a number of com
compromises on these articles but
despite the skepticism that I feel in
this matter that article now comprises
that um the procedure
and putting in place a sufficient
safeguards to be accepted it seems to me
as far as the duration of controls are
concerned I consider it impossible to
accept internal checks on an unlimited
basis
as determined by the member states
because this runs counter to the spirit
of freedom of movement that we've
already talked upon and also it
contradicts the decree of the account
court of justice we've we've often
spoken about rule of law and that must
absolutely be respected and we have to
respect the decisions made by the court
I hope that we are going to find a
negotiation that will allow us to
negotiate an agreement by the end of the
Mandate and to conclude I would just
like to say that in the past 10 years
we've seen
that it's much easier from a political
point of view because of a national
political sensibilities to reintroduce
these internal checks is much more
complicated however
than making that decision to to lift
them afterwards and doubtlessly because
of public opinion on the matter it's not
the role of the European legislators to
introduce additional instruments that
allow them to justify the reintroduction
of internal checks I think we need to
revisit Schengen
and to make sure that it corresponds to
the Schengen spirit thank you
okay thank you very much now um we have
uh questions and answers
so let's start uh Epp nobody wants to
say anything so yeah
thank you uh thank you chair I don't
know if the speakers from the previous
round already
went away or maybe somebody of them
stayed but I just wanted to ask
to whom it may concern like we sometimes
write nobody mentioned the external
borders I understand that this is kind
of a bit different issue but we also
have different rules there I mean in in
September 2022 for instance my home
country is still in a lot Valentine and
Poland introduced Visa ban for Russians
which is absolutely different from these
have been introduced month later by
Finland and very different from Evie's
abandoned had used by other Sharingan
countries which gives very bad
impression when you look at schengeneria
from outside and people who know that
they would not be let in from let's say
Estonia they go over Finland if no
Finland then they go to Italy and of
course if we have this set of different
rules for the people coming outside it's
obvious that we're kind of feeding the
need for internal border checks so maybe
because somebody can also reflect on
that we wrote a commission but Frankly
Speaking we received very long and very
empty letter out of here thank you
okay
yeah no taking things in the next step
when we have the position next time on
this issue here but I'm just uh you know
you know I'm really a little bit
confused is it possible for the
commission just to change
the laws you know you said because
Denmark was for good reasons really uh
accused of vality the same rules when we
just copy pasted the old argument for uh
for prolonging and the the the border
control and in Denmark it's absolutely
it's the police is supposing what's
going on because it they say it's based
on money it's waste of time it's basic
resources it could be but better used if
you want to combat a crimes and get this
groups here then we have all the issues
with the of course with the the pentlers
in this region there and it was I think
it wasn't quite clear that it was a
clear violation of the uh of the uh
saying rules
but no no a process has been opened and
you know if you say I'm not very loyal
to my country yes I am developed by
country which is barely badly rude on
this issue here now so I'm defending my
country uh doing very idiotic things to
a very important region for us which is
lazy Saturdays with nasty speak but it's
also uh the uh the waste of resources
why is the commission not doing anything
about it thank you
thank you somebody else wants to
intervene because I don't have any any
more uh flaws
yeah I know but nobody okay um now um we
have here the former map
um from Lithuania but uh first I want to
ask if the rest of the maps they have
any problem if she it's taking the floor
no okay so go ahead yeah
so as it was hearing I just wanted to
say the about the situation on the
border external border and with regard
to the Visa facilitation agreements
which are not in the hands of the
countries but my question to experts who
is in charge for the Schengen
code implementation at the European
Union level because the commission is
saying that it violates the court every
time when it once without concern of the
member states
and Parliament keeps silence the
situation is looks like that in Belarus
Wagner group military paramilitary group
is setting a campus and according to
Visa facilitation agreement Belarus
citizens can enter European Union at a
let's say very facilitated rules so it
means that paramilitary groups Schengen
can enter singing Lithuania
because Belarus could issue them
documents
into our territory and also into the
territory of the
other member states
so who is in charge for the Visa
facilitation agreements and to the how
to implement the
strictly prohibited enter of the
European Union
this without
interactions of the European commission
and only citizens who are not allowed to
enter Schengen Zona from Romanian
bulgaris I understand because if you are
from this red country Russia Belarus
Ukraine there are no borders there there
is just a
documents are issued by anybody nobody
cares it's house just chaotic situation
and they all can enter uh under
different uh conclusive by the
commission
okay
so now I'm opening the floor to The
Experts let's start with Mr gulzao
thank you just a few more
um
notes um of course from the beginning
the evolution of border control it's
interesting and interesting borders was
related to the hardening of the external
border so there's a strong relation
between the two
but and at the same time
um member states justify temporary
border controls by secondary movements
and also the missing responsibility
sharing of Asylum is an issue here but
at the same time
um I would question whether internal
border controls are an effective measure
to address this issue I think member
states could do more to show that
internal border controls are effective
in
our effective solution to this issue
um and the second point maybe the
commission could also issue an opinion
on the notifications and ask member
states to provide more information about
the threats that they address with the
internal border controls and also put a
burden of proof on them to show that it
is an effective measure maybe small
remarks
I don't have much to add because there
aren't really any questions it's more
comments on the subject
on behalf of the parliament so I'm going
to continue the work to try to find a
joint solution
I can't be 100 that will so sure that
we'll manage it because we have very
very differing positions particularly on
the length of upholding the Border
internal border controls and the reason
for setting them up as well but I do
hope that we will continue to work in
the spirit of Shogun which is trust and
shared our work and that's exactly what
we're trying to do thank you
thank you very much now I'm giving the
photo vice president in Libya Paolo
angel
so thank you very much Dolores first I'd
like to thank you all of you our experts
that we invited and members of
parliament and staff and others that
really were so interested in this
hearing I'd like to apologize for
being
out for 20 minutes 25 minutes for votes
in Africa but then let me say uh bearing
in mind what I heard in the first part
of the three main explanations of this
hearing the first part and then
also with some notes that uh my
assistance sent to me let me say that
first
Schengen is clearly one of the pillars
of European union and I say that today
everybody agrees that if you ask a
citizen of scheng and I if he values the
the freedom of circulation I'd say this
is like Erasmus or like Euro currency
and so on a clear
symbol and advantage of being an
European citizen so this is a
constitutional I'd say symbol of the
European Union by one hand then second
I think that is clear today that there
is an abuse
of member states using the uh internal
borders control
so in some occasions it is totally I'd
say
reasonable to do it if you have a big
event like Olympic Games or uh uh
football championship or something like
this a great initiative of course there
can be security reasons when we had all
these I'd say
terrorist attacks in France or in
Belgium and so during some time this can
be reasonable but it cannot be a
permanent answer
because then you are destroying shame
the simple the simple fact that there is
a permanent check at internal borders
with suspension of Schengen for six
seven eight years this is clearly a
breaching all the system because this is
a disruption of option so we cannot bear
as a system this kind of permanent
exception
I have to say and now I would move to
two examples one that was not referred
here it was referred as an example that
is the Swedish case
but we listened me together with Mr
Lopez agilar the previous government of
Sweden but the position is the same
and the the argumentation was not really
a a a a good and sound one why because
he was saying if I look at organized
crime
there is a direct relation
with having controls at Swedish borders
and to combat diminish reduce it the
activities of organized crime Networks
and this is not an answer because what
we have to say to these countries is you
have to choose if you want to remain or
you want to leave Schengen because you
cannot have the best of Two Worlds that
is I have my own controls but then I
profit from the freedom of circulation
of all the others and so this is
something that we should really face
then let me say
that I don't agree with one of the
experts that said that public health was
not uh uh
a good reason for creating an exception
so about kovid that this was illegal
this is totally wrong in my view
because we have in Schengen sport is
called one exception for internal
control that is security reasons and
relevant or very exceptional in public
interests and public health is an
exceptional public interest of course if
you say ah it's because cancer cancer is
not risen but an epidemic not a pandemic
an epidemic can be a reason because
inside our own countries we have
restrictions to freedom of circulation
in our own countries and this was at
least common sense and law cannot be
against common sense but even even if it
was not common sense this is allowed
because watching and smarter code says
is for external borders public health is
foreseen
but that is public health independent of
any pandemic if you go to the United
States if you go to Australia if you go
to China you have to fulfill something
where you say I don't have this disease
I had this vaccine I don't transport
this kind of materials so for external
borders you can use Earth
even if there is no pandemic only
because you can this is your sovereignty
of course inside borders you cannot use
Public Health in this respect as a
normal thing but if you have a pandemic
this is a relevant I'd say a very
relevant exceptional case of public
interest and so it was not wrong what
was then wrong with the exceptions
during coffee times
it was wrong not to have something that
the commission we have to be Austin
honest proposed that was a common
criteria to establish restrictions to
say if we have this pandemic numbers
in this region then we have this kind of
restriction
if it is more the double we have a kind
of yellow and then we have a kind of red
region so what we should have it was a
common criteria for restrictions not to
say to the countries to the member
states you cannot put restrictions but
they should follow the same criteria so
sometimes they said you cannot come from
Hungary because you have these numbers
but then Germany would say you cannot
come from Austria because you have these
numbers that were totally different
and so this was the problem the problem
is not to have restrictions
with a internal check control when you
have a pandemic or an epidemic the
problem is that you don't have an
uniform criteria for all Europe to say
if you are a Red Zone you can do it if
you are awesome you can do only this if
you are a a green zone you are not
allowed to to to create this and I have
to say that the commission
propose this to all the member states to
say we will have common criteria and
then you can
launch the checks or not
according to the evolution of the
pandemic in your territory or in your
different regions because even it could
happen that you could have internal
control in some regions and not in
others
and so this could work so only to say
that our uh of course I I welcome very
much the the the proposals and the
presentation made by Sylvie guillon and
I think really really need a reform of
schinden Brothers court but we cannot
say that we don't have instruments to
face exceptional situations we have it
the problem today is the countries are
using arguments are using reasons that
are not really
covered by the law and I have to say
they are disproportionate because they
are not necessary as I said
sometimes we have of course sometimes we
have situations where it is needed very
useful to have a internal borders
reinstalled but you cannot prolong this
for seven years
because then this is not changing
this is a fiction and thing and that's
why I think that here we should be very
strict
I understand that the country sometimes
imagine if there is a security threat
you need six months probably we can have
to extend more six months in order to
grant that everything is clean and now
we have proper measures and everything
is okay but you cannot say I have to
keep these seven years you cannot say
I'm going to use these two to combat
organized crime because organized crime
we have to combat all over the territory
of European Union so we have to have
these measures in the external Waters
not internal and so
and this is a bit strange because we are
also in Libya uh working in a lot of
police police Corporation in order to
combat crime in order to end we are
giving to a son I'd say authorization
for exchanging of data that are
sensitive that are important but that we
say okay for this purpose we will allow
with guarantees and checks so we are
also creating a a common uh space of
security and so we don't we should not
have these controls uh when we have
Liberty or freedom and security are
always together
I have to say that if you look at the
Declaration La declaration
the 1789 there is the the right to
freedom and security together
and if you go to almost all the
Constitutions they have these two
so they say we understand to be free you
need to be safe look in some American
Latin American cities
it's so insecure so unsafe that people
are not free they cannot leave home
freely they cannot walk and so on
so we need security but this is a
balance and if you have a common state
of Freedom you also have a common space
of security we are providing police
authorities member states with the
capacity to exchange data in this so
they have to comply with the freedom uh
the respect of the freedom of
circulation because they have the means
and the instruments to check this at the
European level and not only at a local
level so I would conclude saying that I
still have a lot of Hope in in in
Schengen but we can do much better and
also that depends in our security
capacity of the parliament uh I think
that here we have a a a a a good role
and it was really a pleasure to see that
our citizens all across Europe are
worried with this and they come to Petty
in order to really try to fix situations
that they know that are wrong thank you
very much
very interesting so thank you to the
panelists and of uh of course to the
vice president of leeway uh will all
take into account everything you said to
better take our decisions both in the
leeway committee and in the petty
committee
we can move on now to the next